[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates all
I'm gonna say as today as they have
power
and strength as the victims of Jeffrey
Epstein finally had their voices heard
in court their lawyer says federal
prosecutors continued to investigate The
Millionaire sexual predators friends and
associates he assured me that this is a
serious investigation is going to
continue and you know it is always
possible it is possible that there will
be another indictment what does that
mean for one time epstein friends
including President Trump former
President Clinton Prince Andrew of
England and famed Harvard Law Professor
Alan Dershowitz
he says allegations against him are
totally false and he can prove it I
never met her I don't know her it's a
complete and total fabrication plus tens
of thousands dead from the scourge of
powerfully addictive painkillers now the
company that makes oxycontin offers a 12
billion dollar settlements as video
finally emerges of its former president
being grilled by the victims lawyers
know how much the Sackler family has
made off the sale of oxycontin
I don't know but fair to say it's over a
billion dollars it would be fair to say
that yes and our shoutout for the super
states who regularly shows up mainstream
journalists with his big scoops and now
they want him to teach how he does I've
done about trainings for about 2,000
journalists in the last four months New
York Times was Washington Post ABC CBS
Associated Press from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates and good evening and
welcome the reckoning continues for the
many victims the survivors of
millionaires sexual predator Jeffrey
Epstein who authorities say took his own
life in a prison cell
rather than face his accusers in court
but this week the federal judge who
would have overseen that trial allowed
as many of the women who wanted to to
speak in court on the record about their
ordeal and their impact on their lives
more than a dozen women came to the
courthouse saying they were survivors of
Jeffrey
it was a day of emotional tears anger
defies all I'm gonna say it today as
they have power and strength
that's all thank you it was so powerful
in there hearing all the other victims
and very similar stories that I have
endured I wanted to thank the judge for
letting us speak having some closure
it's still gonna be a rough road but I
won't so wanted to thank all the
survivors that had reached out to me as
well and telling me their stories it
really means a lot I'm here for anyone
that went through something similar
nearby US Attorney's Office where the
women went to talk with federal
prosecutors their lawyer Gloria Allred
says she's been assured the
investigation is still extremely active
after the death of the man he assured me
that this is a serious investigation is
going to continue and you know it is
always possible it is possible that
there will be another indictment you
know it phazon when that's not a quote
but I'm summarizing what he said if as
and when there's sufficient evidence for
there to be an indictment so now the
question is what does that mean for
Epstein's one-time friends and
associates most pointedly Prince Andrew
of England videos of the Prince at
Epstein's New York townhouse are now the
talk of London and while he has denied
knowing anything about Epstein's sex
trafficking schemes one of the teenagers
recruited by Epstein continues to claim
in court papers that she was instructed
by him to have sex with the Prince when
she was just 17 an allegation that
Prince has denied that woman Virginia
Joffrey was among those in court this
week accompanied by her high-powered
lawyer David Boies she told reporters
about the prince he knows exactly what
he's done and I hope he comes clean
about it
Joffrey has also claimed in court
filings that she was told to have sex
with famed Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz
that's something mr. dersh which has
strongly denied and joining us now is
Alan Dershowitz via Skype from Martha's
Vineyard mr. dorit's thank you for being
here tonight
tell me again you deny these charges no
ifs ands or buts I never met her I don't
know who she was
I'm the one who went to the u.s. first
and asked for an investigation I went to
the district attorney's office Sciences
office asked for an investigation I
wrote an op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal demanding of yeah I investigate
B I have nothing to hide I did
absolutely nothing wrong and now we have
emails from DAR perfect right to her and
from her which admit she didn't know I
was she didn't meet me in her manuscript
she was told to put me in her book
because I would be a good person because
I wrote reversal of fortune or I was
Epstein's loiter she had to be told that
I was Epstein's lawyer so then she puts
me in the book as somebody she did not
have sex with somebody who she saw
talking to Jeffrey Epstein about
business this is a book in which she
includes many many people another
Harvard professor named Stephen many
many other people she describes in
detail all of her sexual encounters with
these people
and then she describes in detail seeing
me once and not having sex with me so
the evidence is just overwhelming that
after she met David Boies she suddenly
changed her story she had never ever
alleged to her best friend to her
boyfriend to the FBI that I was one of
the people she had sex with then
suddenly years later she meets David
Boies in the middle of 2014 and suddenly
she is pressured that's our own word she
felt pressured to name me in order to
get a lot of money from Leslie Wexner
the whole plan was to name me in public
and then David Boies went privately to
Leslie Wexner and essentially said to
him if you don't want to have happen to
you what happened to Alan Dershowitz
there are ways of resolving this they
had a big meeting between David Boies
and and waxing his lawyer and after that
meeting Lexington's name disappears
Wexner had been accused of having sex
with the same woman Virginia Robert sue
Frey between five and ten times and also
being made to wear victorious
lingerie and suddenly this accusation
disappears after that meeting there only
two possible explanations one David
Boies didn't believe her and so did the
right thing but if you didn't believe
her why would he believe her about me or
a second that some payments were made in
order hush money was paid we don't know
that but I've asked the federal
government and the state government to
investigate whether this was part of an
extortion plan all I know is that I
never met this woman
period I have travel records that prove
it I have a tape recording from David
Boies in which he says after reviewing
the records it would have been
impossible for you to have been in the
place as my client says you were and my
client was wrong
simply wrong those are his words there's
no context that that could be out of
it's an admission by her lawyer not
knowing that he was being paid an
admission by her lawyer that his client
made up the whole story about me that's
the truth that's the reality that's will
come out at a trial the investigation is
continuing into associates friends of
Jeffrey Epstein have you talked to the
FBI about that aspect of it have they
asked to have you come in and testify
I'd love to come in and testify I went
to the FBI asked I wrote a piece for The
Wall Street Journal I think it's a good
thing that the investigation is
continuing but the investigation should
be complete it should decide who were
real victims and who are making up
stories remember
committing perjury repeated perjury and
falsely accusing somebody a great is a
very very serious crime suborning
perjury by a lawyer is a very serious
crime so I want the US Attorney's Office
the FBI the district attorney's office
to look at the totality of the
circumstances and to decide who's
telling the truth in his life I have
sworn under oath I have never met this
woman when I went to see the FBI I told
them I know the rules if I lie to you I
go to jail I want to tell you
unequivocally I never met this woman if
she says under oath that she ever met me
she will be committing perjury and I
want the FBI and the Justice Department
decide who to prosecute you can't allow
two affidavits to be in front of a
federal court which are categorically
inconsistent one of which says I never
met her the other
one said she had sex with one of us is
lying it's not me I want the FBI to
investigate and let the chips fall where
they may
mr. Suri this dish was a question for
you from our control room from executive
producer Rhonda Schwartz do you have
questions about the death of Jeffrey
Epstein his lawyer said earlier this
week his injuries were consistent with
the homicide what do you think I have no
reason to believe there was anything
other than a suicide my own view and I
haven't spoken to Jeffrey Epstein a long
time I haven't seen him in years and
years and years remember I stopped being
his lawyer ten years ago but my own view
is that he had made a decision that he
would probably spend the rest of his
life in prison he couldn't bear that
reality and he decided the best way out
for him was to take his own life I don't
know that and I don't want to say
anything that's inconsistent with the
evidence of what his own lawyers say let
there be a full and complete
investigation of that you have any
doubts at all about the suicide then I
have no doubts but I have an open mind
if there are as there is evidence that
would show something different I don't
know who would a have a motive to kill
him or be who would have the capacity to
kill him but you know I I think a lot of
Americans think there's something you
remember we've really live in an age of
postback age where people have so many
doubts about everything that's about the
FBI of the Comey report came out today
about the FBI people have doubts and I
think we have to resolve these deaths by
facts but facts matter and fact truth
that I never met Virginia Roberts who
for a she should be prosecuted she
should end up in jail even if she was a
victim of Jeffrey Epstein she cannot
make a victim of me in revenge against
Jeffrey Epstein she ought to be fully
investigated and if it's concluded as is
clearly the case that she has committed
repeated perjury cheer to go to jail her
lawyers ought to be investigating too
they suborn perjury they also should be
prosecuted Alan Dershowitz thank you so
much for joining us tonight thank you
coming up next another reckoning this
time for the companies who made
oxycontin and other powerful addictive
painkillers for the first time the
videos are now public of one of those
executives being questioned by lawyers
for the victims
when we return
this was also a week of reckoning for
the companies that make the powerful and
addictive painkillers that had been
blamed for the deaths of tens of
thousands of Americans a judge Nicola
Houma or the Johnson & Johnson company
to pay more than 570 million dollars and
more significantly the makers of
oxycontin Purdue Pharma is now offering
to settle all of the cases against it
with a payment of ten to twelve billion
dollars the companies owned by members
of the Sackler family they've made
millions of dollars themselves off the
sales oxycontin and for the first time
this week we have the videos of Richard
Sackler the former president of the
company being questioned by lawyers for
those suing the company he has Purdue
Frederic or Purdue farmer made of the
sale of oxycontin I don't know okay do
you know how much the Sackler family has
made off the sale of oxycontin I don't
know but fair to say it's over a billion
dollars it would be fair to say that yes
do you know if it's over ten billion
dollars I don't think so
I don't know joining us now to talk
about the settlers and the oxycontin
case is Barry Meyer the former New York
Times reporter who more than any other
journalist helped to expose the
marketing machination z' of the Purdue
Pharma company Barry thanks for joining
us what do you make of this deposition
the document itself had come out but now
the videos here we see mr. sacra himself
testified well I think that his
deposition testimony has to be taken
into context with some other information
that was recently revealed as I wrote in
painkiller and in the New York Times
last year
federal prosecutors investigated Perdue
back in 2007 and among the things they
discovered was that in one year alone a
2001 trust affiliated with the Sackler
family received 1 billion dollars in
profits so while Richard Sackler Sackler
might know that not know the exact
figure they receive we do know that in
one year alone it was 1 billion dollars
let's take a look at a second portion of
the south of deposition haven't you do
with the
Bharathi do you know if reps that
promoted and sold oxycontin sometimes
ended up making over $250,000 a year
I've heard that that was the case they
didn't sure it was unusual and then your
top sellers were rewarded with trips to
Bermuda or London in what was called the
toppers program is that correct yes and
during the first five years of
oxycontin's release Perdue more than
doubled the size of its sales force
correct that's correct
do you believe produce marketing was
overly aggressive no
[Applause]
yeah do you believe produce marketing
was appropriate I believe so Jerry Mari
what do you make of that the marketing
was really a serious question for them
well dr. shackle is obviously entitled
to believe whatever he wants but the
facts are these in 2007 the company that
his family owns Purdue Pharma pled
guilty to criminally misleading doctors
and patients in the marketing of
oxycontin secondly several years before
that his company compensated
incentivized theirselves reps in a way
that no other company did incentivize
them to sell essentially stronger doses
of oxycontin and because they were being
paid on the value of a prescription
rather than simply the number of
prescriptions they sold so the more
expensive prescriptions the higher
dosage prescriptions generated higher
commissions for the sales reps all this
at a time when they were aware there
were serious issues that it was stronger
and more addictive than being advertised
well I mean if we go on what federal
prosecutors uncovered during their
investigation of the company they
believe that executives of Purdue knew
almost immediately after the drug
appeared on the market that it was being
abused that it's abuse was growing and
that they concealed that information
from regulators lawmakers patients and
the public I mean the company and the
executives deny that but in the
documents that I reviewed the internal
prosecution memo written by Justice
Department lawyers they lay out that
case so is there a new prosecution
likely because of all the information
that has come out you know I'm not privy
to what the Justice Department is or
isn't doing right now but I believe that
there may be active investigations
underway yes and in terms of the civil
lawsuits brought by
dates with the Purdue Pharma offering to
pay up to 12 billion dollars in
settlement and the family would then
sell off the company take out its
interests yes basically what the company
is saying is if you leave us alone
we're going to end our involvement with
Purdue Pharma with its overseas
subsidiaries and we'd like to make this
payment to buy peace for ourselves going
forward and the money that came out of
that would go to treat people who are
still addicted to it suffering from
oxycontin and other painkillers yeah
hopefully I mean there's the structure
of what where those funds would go is
not clear yet but one would hope that
the vast majority of those monies would
go to addiction treatment well Barry
Mara thank you so much for joining us
and congratulations on such good work
when we come back our shoutout for the
super sleuth those big scoops showed
major newspapers and networks some gaps
in their own reporting efforts
and our shutout tonight is for someone
who is not a journalist but who's a
building to come up with some major
stories has got big news organizations
begging him to tell them how he did it
it was in the middle of a blizzard
Washington DC when Seamus Hughes scored
one of his many big scoops this year it
was a snowy day my kids are playing the
front yard they were building a snowman
and I needed a break from cleaning off
the car and for fun Hughes is the kind
of person who likes to look at a website
called pacer that records the activities
of federal criminal courts around the
country documents have been posted on
pacer in Maryland that day and came
across it what he came across was the
indictment of a member of the US Coast
Guard who had purchased a huge quantity
of weapons and authorities say was about
to use them to carry out a mass murder
we just tweeted it out and then by the
time the Snowman was was done we had
about 10,000 retweets on it it was a
huge story that made headlines across
the country investigators say he was
planning a major attack on innocent
civilians they say they found at least
15 guns and 1000 rounds of ammunition
prosecutors are calling him a domestic
terrorist a story that might have gone
unnoticed by other journalists but for
Seamus Hughes and he used the same
sleuthing technique to break the story
of the government's indictment of
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange I was
looking at a case in Virginia of a guy
who was supporting terrorism and the
prosecutor that case accidentally filed
information related to Julian Assange so
entirely serendipitous entirely
serendipitous Julian Assange in an
unsealed court filing suggesting he
might be criminally charged WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange has been charged
under seal another major story for which
the country's leading journalist ODE
Hughes a giant thank you I think there's
there's two things going on right one is
a lack of training when it comes to open
source collection and looking at at
court records and the other thing is
chasing the news of the day you know the
late the latest presidential tweet will
get you more clicks than a deep dive in
a Coast Guard
individual who was thinking about
joining neo nazism and so that's you go
in areas where nobody else is really uh
farming yeah I think that's that's fair
there's no in farming and apparel we're
also losing a lot of journalists in the
last couple years as the industry
constraints and so you're not having the
same I used to have on there these local
newspapers don't have federal court
reporters sitting at the courthouse
pulling stuff obsessive document digger
and it has brought Hughes a lot of
attention with profiles on CBS News and
elsewhere Hughes isn't really even a
journalist he works at George Washington
University's terror tracking section a
former US government official who worked
in the National Counterterrorism Center
so now he's busy teaching actual
journalists how to do their jobs better
I've done about trainings for about
2,000 journalists in the last four
months New York Times Washington Post
ABC CBS Associated Press basically
teaching them the tricks of the trade it
all began as Hugh's work to track young
Americans who have been recruited by
Isis in al Qaeda
he says the threat from those groups is
far from over of as much concern to
Hughes is the spike in what can be
called domestic terrorism linked to
groups overseas I'm not sure the media's
really picked up the transnational
nature of domestic terrorism and so it's
not necessarily domestic terrorism it's
also international and you see these
white supremacist groups have links to
organizations in Europe and in Australia
New Zealand and I think it's going to be
a learning curve in the short term
there's also you have to think of we've
had you know nearly 20 years of
understanding groups like al Qaeda and
Isis ideology and understanding the
white supremacists and even sovereign
citizen ideology is a different animal
and so there's gonna be a learning curve
why do you do it if you give me a piece
of information and tell me you know I've
got two days to figure it out I'm gonna
roll up my sleeves make some phone calls
get on a plane and start talking to
people because that's the only way
you're gonna figure it out well thank
you so much keep up the good work and so
a very big shout out to Seamus Hughes
who's taught a lot of journalists
including this one how to do their jobs
much better well that's our program for
the
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here next week